bonjour mon
Général bonjour Jérôme Durin président
de la commission d'enquête à mes côté
Étienne BLANC rapporteur et quelques
collègues sénateur sénatrice de la
commission d'enquête dans la salle merci
de répondre à cette demande
d'aition je vais vous soumettre à
l'obligation de prestation de serment
qui est requise devant une commission
d'enquête
parlementaire puisque un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête serait
passible de peine qui sont prévu aux
articles
434-13-1-1 du Code pénal et donc je vais
vous inviter à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure je le jure merci euh on s'est donné
1 heure écart pour échanger je vous
propose qu'on commence par un échange
sur la base de ce que vous avez envie de
nous dire et puis ensuite on on
enchaînera par le jeu des questions
réponse si ça vous
convient ça me convient monsieur le
Président merci mer bonjour monsieur le
Président messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames messieurs euh donc
euh je vais vous présenter quelques
éléments sur le le trafic de drogue
pendant je pense une 15 vingtaine de
minutes euh et puis ensuite je me
soumettrai bien volontiers à à vos
questions euh
donc ce dont je vais parler c'est
évidemment la vision du trafic de
stupéfiants en Europe tel que Europol
peut
l'avir depuis sa
position au je dirais au niveau européen
peut-être d'abord quelques quelques
rappels qui peuvent être utiles sur
Europol donc Europol comme vous le savez
c'est l'agence de l'Union européenne
pour la coopération des services
répressifs Europol n'a pas de pouvoir
exécutif Europol
n'évalue ni ne contrôle les les unités
de police nationale Europol apporte son
soutien aux enquêtes des forces de
police de gendarmerie de
douane des États-membres à partir du
moment où elles sont
transfrontalières c'est-à-dire où il y a
au moins deux de nos États-membres qui
sont concernés à l'exception évidemment
de la matière terroriste où Europol peut
soutenir une
investigation y compris quand un seul
des at membbrre est concerné euh nous
fournissons principalement et c'est sur
quoi le l'agence a été
construite nous nous fournissons une
aide à l'analyse des données depuis le
siège de l'agence qui se trouve à la au
Pays-Bas
et sur place en déplaçant des enquêteurs
euh les drogue et Europol c'est je
dirais le début de l'histoire puisque
comme vous le savez au tout début b de
sa création l'agence s'est
appelé l'agence Europol
drog le notre quartier général ici à lae
sert aussi de centre de coordination
pour les opérations de grande envergure
nous apportons aussi aux États-membres
et aux forces de l'ordre un soutien
financier pour développer leurs
investigations que ce soit dans le
cadre de leurs enquêtes ou dans le cadre
des programmes impact la forme
européenne de lutte contre les menaces
criminelles
euh nous disposons ici à
l'agence d'officiers de liaison qui
viennent
de aujourd'hui des 27 États-membres
évidemment mais au total aujourd'hui de
52 pays avec lesquels Europol a des
accords ou la Commission a des des
accord pour des échanges de données soit
de données stratégiques soit des données
opérationn
c'est à peu près 250 officiers de
liaison qui vont des 27 États-membres
jusque aux États-Unis aux Américains au
colombien et cetera qui sont ici avec
lesquels nous pouvons travailler
directement avec
eux Europol ne communique pas de
statistique par entité policière et par
pays Europol donne une vision globale au
niveau
européen alors maintenant si je
m'intéresse de plus près au au sujet à
votre sujet d'aujourd'hui l'Union
européenne en fait et les drogues B
l'Union européenne est un continent sur
lequel on
produit donc il y a de la production de
drogue il y a du transit de drogue et
c'est un évidemment un continent dans
lequel il y a de l'importation de
drogue pourquoi je précise ça parce que
souvent on a la vision d'un continent
qui ne fait qu'importer de la drogue en
fait on en produit aussi je vais y venir
et euh et on on ne fait et parfois on en
exporte même euh les modalités de ces
trafics de drogue sont en constante
évolution mais ce qui ne change pas
c'est la rentabilité
importante très importante de ce trafic
qui reste l'un des marchés criminels les
plus
lucratifs au niveau mondial
euh les principaux constats qu'on a pu
faire ces dernières années je vais y
revenir sont des constats qui ont été
basé sur des observations qui ont pu
être faites par les enquêtes qu'on a pu
soutenu soutenir et en particulier par
les grandes enquêtes qui ont été initié
où la France a toujours eu une part sur
l'interception de messagerie crypté de
communication en crchat ou
skycc qui ont permis d'en apprendre
beaucoup sur la façon dont les criminels
travaillaient dans ce domaine du trafic
euh juste deux chiffres pour vous donner
une idée de de ce sur quoi de quoi on
parle à Europol donc nous
avons une unité drogue qui fait partie
d'un centre d'expertise peut-être
j'aurais dû préciser nous avons quatre
centres d'expertise systématique ici à
la direction des opérations d'Europol un
centre sur la criminalité organisée un
centre sur la
cybercriminalité un centre sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme et un centre sur la
criminalité économique et financière au
sein du centre sur la
criminalité organisée nous avons une
unité drogue cette unité en 2022 j'ai
pas les chiffres consolidé de 2023 donc
je vous donne ceux de 2022 elle a
soutenu
335 opération ce qu'on appelle une
opération c'est une grande enquête
internationale euh liée au trafic de
drogue donc 335 en 2022 le chiffre sera
supérieur en 2023 même s'il n'est pas
définitivement connu aujourd'hui et nous
avons conduit 40 journées d'action
c'est-à-dire quasiment une par semaine
sur le sujet des drogues au cours de
cette année
2022 alors si j'évoque rapidement euh
les tendances des é tion les routes et
les pays par type de drogue en fait il y
en a quatre grands types le premier
c'est le cannabis donc ça reste la
drogue la plus consommée dans l'Union
européenne et ça devrait le
rester ces 10 dernières années la
puissance du marché au niveau cannabis a
augmenté on constate une grande
diversification des produits avec
l'arrivée de cannabinoïde synthétique ou
semi-ynthétique sur le marché et puis
les dernières évolutions c'est une
culture du cannabis sur le territoire de
l'Union Européenne de plus en plus
importante que ce
soit outdoor à l'extérieur comme on dit
ou alors
indoor avec de plus en plus une culture
du cannabis en fait qui s'est développé
à l'intérieur même de l'Europe pour une
consommation principalement euh du
produits non raffinés c'est-à-dire pas
en en Barret de chit euh la cocaïne je
vais très vite hein parce que je veux
pas prendre beaucoup de votre temps le
trafic de cocaïne vers l'Union
européenne a connu une augmentation
significative au cours des dernières
années qui est lié au fait que l'Europe
est devenu le principal marché de la
cocaïne les les drogues synthétiques
ayant envahi le marché américain et en
raison de leur coût et cetera ayant
limité en fait le l'importance du marché
américain au niveau mondial donc les
trafiquants ont cherché des débouchés en
Europe la pureté est plus la plus élevée
que jamais du du produit euh la cocaïne
est
acheminé dans l'Union européenne
principalement en terme de masse par
container maritime provenant d'Amérique
du Sud évidemment avec parfois et le
plus souvent d'ailleurs ces derniers
temps des rebonds dans certains pays
africains et des points de départ qui
ont varié
euh puisque aujourd'hui ils sont plutôt
du côté du Brésil ou de l'équateur que
directement depuis les ports par exemple
colombien les ports d'arrivées en
revanche évidemment par la masse du
trafic euh les ports de l'Europe du Nord
en particulier enverse Rotterdam et
Hambourg sont les ports les plus
impactés mais ceci dit tous les ports
européens peuvent être euh concernés et
on aura d'ailleurs dans jours à enerse
sous le cadre de la Présidence belge le
lancement d'une
[Applaudissements]
initiative dans ce domaine je cro en
général je je crois quand vous déplacez
vos papiers ça frotte sur le micro et si
ça rend les choses
difficiles merci
merciess de faire moins de
bruit le l'héroïne aujourd'hui bon ça
reste un des problè m les plus
importants liés à la drogue en raison de
la de la nocivité de cette drogue et du
nombre de décès qui sont liés
euh le marché est plutôt considéré comme
stable ces C dernières années euh dans
certains États-membres on a vu
apparaître des opioïdes synthétiques
comme le
fantanil qu'on surveille de très près
mais qui n'a pas fait réellement de
percer aujourd'hui évidemment il arrive
principalement d'Asie
d'Afghanistan majorité ement c'est pour
ça aussi qu'on surveille beaucoup la la
la je dirais l'attitude du régime à
Kabou pour vis-à-vis de cette drogue et
puis les routes sont soit la route
balcanique soit une route une route plus
au nord il peut y avoir aussi des
arrivées par par voie maritime à partir
de port d'Iran en
particulier les enfin les drogues
synthétiques la production de drogue de
sy a généralement lieu à l'intérieur de
l'Union européenne les drogues sont
ensuite distribuées sur non seulement
sur les marchés européens mais aussi
parfois au niveau mondial euh les sites
de production sont autant qu'on puisse
le savoir aujourd'hui sont
principalement soit en Europe de l'Est
en Pologne ou dans les Pays-Bas en
Belgique
euh la production est est importante
elle se développe et comme je l'évoquais
euh par exemple pour la métamphétamine
ou
l'amphétamine des produits sont exportés
à partir d'Europe sur des marchés qui
sont demandeurs par exemple l'Australie
ou la Nouvelle-Zélande
euh voilà pour ça pour les drogues un
mot euh
important sur
les alors on on agit plutôt sur le haut
de la chaîne c'est-à-dire pas tellement
la distribution mais plutôt la
production et le transport je dirais le
le le le trafic de gros entre guillemets
euh les les quantités de drogu euh sont
évidemment très importantes qui sont
arrivées donc l'usage des plateforme en
ligne qui est important pour la
distribution les moins au niveau global
en revanche euh les messagerie cryptée
comme on a pu le le voir euh sont
importantes euh pour les communications
de criminels qui ont désormais une
empreinte mondiale et qui gèent leur
trafic depuis des zones géographiques
dans lesquelles ils se sentent à l'abri
à l'abri de la main de la justice des
pays qui les
pourchasse plus ou moins
protégé et
donc ils ont crucialement besoin de ces
moyens de
communication qu'il souhait
crypter aujourd'hui un tiers des groupes
criminels signalé en Europe au moins
sont infliqués dans le trafic de drogue
euh la production comme je l'ai dit est
importante les deux marqueurs
véritablement cruciaux qui sont
apparus et qui sont désormais visibles
dans un certain nombre d'États et qui
sont apparus à travers les messageries
cryptés c'est d'abord une augmentation
de l'usage de la violence par les
groupes criminels non seulement des
problèmes commerciaux en entre eux mais
aussi pour s'installer dans certaines
zones en particulier des HES logistiques
où ils ont besoin d'avoir une emprise
pour pouvoir par exemple sortir la
marchandise des ports de certains
aéroports ou de différentes voies de
communication cette violence elle se
développe comme des pays autour du port
d'enverse en Belgique ou aux Pays-Bas ou
encore en en Suède
euh comme on la connaît nous en France
je dirais dans dans dans des zones euh
par exemple à Marseille ou ailleurs euh
ça se répand l'usage de la violence et
on le voit il compris dans notre pays le
deuxième élément clé c'est l'usage de la
corruption euh les criminels trafiquant
de drogue ont des moyens euh quasi
limités et ils cherchent toujours à
acheter en fait des informations à
acheter des accès à certaines zones pour
rentrer ou sortir du produit euh et
cetera donc il faut un usage assez
massif euh de la corruption parfois
d'ailleurs euh euh combiné avec l'usage
de la violence ces organisations
criminelles qu'on appelle ici plutôt
aujourd'hui des réseaux criminels euh
plutôt que organisation parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait ils sont à la fois
très organisés mais aussi ils ont une
forme un peu horizontale avec beaucoup
de collaboration entre eux euh pour
pouvoir se reconstituer rapidement et
ils sont très résistants face à l'action
des forces de l'ordre euh c'est un peu
comme uneidre à qui de temps en temps on
on coupe une tête qui ensuite repousse
euh je je voulais également
évoquer dans ce domaine là donc ces
organisations très très horizontales
avec des chefs souvent les têtes de
réseau qui se trouvent comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure en dehors de
l'Union Européenne dans des pays où
l'action policière ou l'action
judiciaire à partir de chez nous
apparaît plus compliqué à mener pour des
questions de
coopération des des forces
locales le plus souvent parfois des
problèmes de cadre juridiqu euh qui ne
sont pas équivalents
euh et cetera dernière partie importante
euh c'est euh que ces organisations
criminelles utilisent les services
d'autres organisations criminelles euh
en anglais on appelle ça crime as a
service c'est une sorte de service
criminel qui est proposé à ces
organisations avec une forme de division
du travail vous avez des organisations
criminelles qui maîtrisent euh le flux
logistique d'autres qui maîtrisent les
points d'entrée ou les points de sortie
d'autres qui maîtrisent la production
d'autres qui maîtrisent la distribution
et d'autres qui
maîtrisent le blanchiment et les flux
financiers et je terminerai cette brève
introduction en évoquant ces flux ces
flux financiers le blanchiment la saisie
la confiscation des
avoirs qui reste un domaine qui est trop
peu
travaillé avec trop peu d'unités
spécialisées euh face à des criminels
qui eux se sont puissamment organisés
pour conserver euh le maximum de
l'argent qu'ils ont gagné dans leur
trafic donc on assiste à des
des un blanchiment d'argent à grande
échelle qui a évolué vers des des des
schémas complexes qui sont proposés par
des des des groupes criminels qui se
sont spécialisés dans le domaine
euh et qui sont capables de bouger des
sommes
considérables d'un point à l'autre du
globe en quelques secondes par des
systèmes de compensation occules par
l'utilisation qu'on voit aussi euh de
cryptoonnaie parfois mais aussi avec
tout un système bancaire occulte basé
sur la confiance basé sur les relations
personnelles et qui permettent de bouger
parfois des millions d'euros entre entre
deux endroits de les réinvestir de les
blanchir en les sortant du système
bancaire traditionnel pour les y faire
reerentrer évidemment quand c'est
nécessaire
uniquement voilà un petit peu ce que je
pouvais dire en
guise d'introduction euh j'ai sans doute
pas touché tous les domaines mais l'idée
c'était de vous donner une première une
première approche et de vous laisser du
temps puissiez éventuellement poser des
questions plus
précises merci beaucoup euh mon Général
ben c'est notre rapporteur Étienne blanc
qui prend la main merci mon général de
ces informations et nous avons constaté
depuis le début de nos travaux et
l'importance que peuvent avoir les
politiques et de lutte contre le
blanchiment la saisie des avoirs
illégalement constitués et quelle est
selon vous et quelle suggestion vous
pouvez faire pour que l'on améliore en
France ce système de confiscation et de
lutte contre le blanchiment c'est ma
première question vous l'avez tout à
l'heure on est un peu court sur ces
sujets-là en Europe est-ce que la France
est moins mieux placé que d'autres pays
européens et on aimerait recueillir
votre avis sur le sujet et et la
deuxième question c'est celle qui touche
aux
cryptoonnaie
aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de services se sont lancés dans des
investigations assez lourdes sur le
sujet et et on découvre l'ampleur du
phénomène et les crypto monnaiees
aujourd'hui permettent de régulariser et
de blanchir toute une
série de produits très divers et issus
d'activit criminelle donc là aussi nous
aimerions connaître les actions
qu'Europol a pu encourager accompagner
et pour lutter contre ce phénomène et
qu'est-ce qui fait défaut aujourd'hui
dans la réglementation et la législation
européenne pour lutter efficacement sur
l'usage illicite de ces
cryptomonnais merci pour votre question
monsieur le rapporteur euh bon sur sur
sur la première question sur le le
blanchiment ça reste un sujet très
compliqué à
travailler en
particulier pour liier en fait
l'infraction de trafic de drogue avec
l'argent qui est blanchi parce qu'il
faut à un moment réussir à faire un
lien qui est extrêmement compliqué qui
requiert souvent des
investigations longues et
difficiles la France n'est pas moins
bien placée que que d'autres pays je
pense que il y a tout le monde a des
difficultés dans ce domaine-là
euh parce que
ben c'est extrêmement difficile on est
face à des des spécialistes euh parfois
euh euh très très évolués euh de de de
de système de blanchiment à travers des
sociétés écran et cetera qui sont
difficiles à remonter on a aussi et ça
c'est c'est vraiment euh un sujet comme
je l'expliquais tout un système bancaire
occulte
euh donc qui qui qui n'est pas du
tout qu'on peut pas contrôler comme ça
je pense qu'il y a un des moyens en tout
cas que nous on
encourage c'est de de le contrôle en
fait des de toutes les les achats
évidemment liquides et de l'argent
liquide qui se qui franchit les
frontières qui se balade d'un endroit à
l'autre avec des obligations de
déclaration qui doivent être importantes
et puis surtout une mise en relation des
éléments liés quand on détecte par
exemple une personne qui trimbal un
million d'euros je sais pas moi par
exemple entre la France et l'Espagne que
immédiatement on puisse avoir des
investigations qui démarrent des
échanges d'information au niveau
international de façon à ce qu'on
reconstitue euh les choses de de manière
générale et je le je le dirai plusieurs
reprises dans mon propos le partage de
l'information et en particulier le
partage en temps réel de l'information
utile est absolument crucial et nous à
Europol c'est des choses qu'on voit tous
les jours c'est-à-dire que parfois il
nous manque
l'information qui nous servirait à faire
le lien entre tel individu qui a déjà
été pris trois fois dans trois états EUR
indifférent simplement il y a pas eu de
mise en rapport des informations
recueillies dans ces trois états et je
parle pas des états-tiers dans lesquels
ça peut arriver aussi pour votre
question sur les les cryptomonnaaies oui
c'est un c'est un domaine dans lequel
Europol a investi depuis un moment avec
des capacités d'enquête avec des
spécialistes en particulier il y a
quelques outils qui sont indispensables
qui sont parfois un peu cher à l'achat
ou à à la location mais euh l'essentiel
quand même du succès repose sur la
matière grise et la formation
d'enquêteurs euh spécialisé pour
remonter dans la blockchain les les les
sign les lignes de cryptomonnaie parce
que l'avantage des cryptoommonnaaies
c'est comme elles sont inscrites dans la
blockchain je dirais c'est pas
modifiable tout est traçable euh mais
simplement pour le tracer c'est
évidemment extrêmement compliqué après
c'est un secteur que les criminels ont
investi très rapidement parce qu'il a
été il est encore mais il a été hier
plus qu'aujourd'hui
sousréglementé en particulier les les
les réglementations pour connaître qui
est derrière les différents wallettes
les portefeuilles de cryptoonnaie a été
au départ été quasiment inexistante puis
c'est un domaine qui est en cours de
régulation Europol participe d'ailleurs
à des travaux dans ce domainelà comme on
participe et on conseille je dirais au
niveau de l'Union
européenne les mesures qui sont prises
aujourd'hui dans le ce qu'on appelle le
antimonroing package qui est en train de
se monter avec une
autorité une autorité antiblanchiment au
niveau
européen qui sera moins dans
l'investigation mais plus dans dans je
dirais l'organisation du secteur et
l'échange d'information avec par exemple
un registre européen des comptes
bancaires et cetera en fait pour les
cryptomonnaies je pense que une des clés
c'est de réglementer les cryptoonnaaies
aussi de façon aussi pertinente et au
niveau mondiale globale ce qui est une
difficulté que on peut réglementer le
secteur
bancaire puisque et à partir de là je
dirais n nos investigations seront
seront plus faciles puisqu'on saura qui
est der arrière ceci dit c'est important
aussi que les services d'enquête se
forment sur ces sur ces domainesl parce
que évidemment c'est des domaines qui
continueront d'être
utilisés aujourd'hui les constatations
qu'on fait c'est que les les les les
criminels en particulier les trafiquants
de drogue utilisent les cryptomonnaaies
avec euh intérêt pour quand il s'agit de
de bouger des sommes importantes d'un
point à un autre dans le Globe parce que
ça peut être fait en quelques secondes
en revanche ils laissent souvent pas
leur argent euh en cryptomonnaie trop
longtemps parce que comme il y a des
fluctuations euh il n'aime pas perdre je
dirais euh l'argent donc il il le bouge
et il le ressortent rapidement euh pour
en faire autre chose ou pour le blanchir
dans des activités qui apparaissent
légales la la
France dispose d'un d'un
outil qui est reconnu par toutes les
personnes que nous avons interrogé sur
la question du
blanchiment et c'est l'inversion de la
présomption vous êtes reconnu comme
trafiquant vous avez un patrimoine c'est
à vous de justifier que vous l'avez
constitué légalement et alors deux
questions la première est-ce que tous
les pays européens
disposent de cette légis
particulière et est-ce que selon vous
partant ça faciliterait les travaux
d'Europol et si tous les pays avaient
harmonisé leur
législation en se dotant de cette
présomption et puis la la deuxième
question c'est sur la circulation des
espèces la France a mis en place une
réglementation au-delà de 1000 € on ne
peut pas payer en espèce il exception
qui est faite pour les acquisitions de
véhicules une autre qui est faite pour
les importations depuis
enfin l'entrée de fond depuis l'étranger
est-ce que selon vous il y a des
dispositifs d'amélioration pour la
France mais surtout une meilleure
harmonisation européenne parce qu'on
peut laisser entendre qu'un certain
nombre d'espèces quitent la France pour
être
blanchie par des comptes bancaires
particulièrement officiels dans d'autres
pays d'Européens qui ne n'appliquent pas
une réglementation trop stricte sur les
montants de versement en espèce sur les
comptes est-ce que vous avez une opinion
sur ce
sujet-là alors sur sur votre première
question
euh le le cadre juridique qui existe en
France n n'est pas à ma connaissance
bon on on le pratique mais on est j'ai
pas fait une étude
exhausive sur la pratique mais pour moi
c'est pas du tout pratiqué dans tous les
ét état européens donc si s'il pouvait y
avoir une une harmonisation enfin
Europol on plaide toujours pour une
forme d'harmonisation
[Musique]
euh européenne dans dans dans ces
domaines là donc évidemment euh si on
pouvait avoir un cadre harmonisé
euh pour que l'inversion comme vous
l'avez dit de la charge de la preuve
euh en matière de de de de détention
d'un patrimoine et cetera soit comment
dire généralisé au niveau européen ça ne
pourrait avoir que des effets positifs
il faut aussi que la mesure soit
appliquée parce
que la législation existe j'ai pas de
statistique et de pourcentage
d'application mais il me semble que
aussi dans
l'application de cette mesure à tous les
trafiquant de de de drogue il pourrait y
avoir aussi des progrès à faire sachant
qu'un certain nombre font leurs
investissements hors d'Europe hein euh
et là on pourrait aussi évoquer
peut-être des
actions
diplomatique pas seulement européenne
mais plus
internationale pour progresser dans ce
domaine là mais pour répondre à votre
question le cadre juridique ne me semble
pas partagé partout en Europe et s'il
l'était ça pourrait être positif sur
votre seconde question sur le le le
mouvement des espèces bon là aussi
euh je pense que il
faut en tout cas nous euh du plan des
enquêteurs
euh il est clair
que tous les
transferts de liquide important euh
déclaré
euh évidemment euh sont importants à
être tracés et que dans ce domaine là
aussi une forme d'harmonisation
européenne serait la bienvenue il semble
quand même qu'il y a des pratiques dans
certains pays
issu de de je dirais de de de pratique
local nationale et cetera où la
réticence est plus importante il en va
de même par exemple sur les dépôts
bancaires he on a vu des dépôts
bancaires dans C un pays d'Europe de
l'Est de montants assez considérables
après le début de la guerre en Ukraine
sur lesquels on s'est posé la question
de leur origine euh sans sans avoir
véritablement de de réponse donc là il y
a aussi et là dans le dispositif anti
blanchiment que l'Union européenne est
en train de mettre en place je pense que
il y a va y avoir du travail dans ce
domainel pour je dirais là aussi
harmonie is et faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un meilleur contrôle après je dois
vous avouer que on voit quand même
beaucoup de
trafiquants passer complètement sous les
radars c'est-à-dire que il transfèrent
l'argent parfois physiquement de manière
complètement illégale dans le coffre
d'une voiture ou dans un sac dans un bus
qui fait un trajet en Europe ou en
dehors de
l'Europe et et ça c'est extrêmement
difficile à détecter parce que c'est un
trafic de mules entre guillemets qui
transporte des plus ou moins grosses
sommes qui vont d'un point à l'autre et
puis il y a tout ce système que
j'évoquais rapidement de de de systèm de
compensation avec des personnes qui on a
eu des dossiers he dans lesquels on a vu
que ça existait où vous déposez 200000 €
à une personne en France par exemple et
immédiate
une personne dans un pays X du golf par
exemple ou du
Moyen-Orient reçoit 200000 € dans
l'heure après
que le premier est envoyé un sms au
2uxè ça alors c'est complètement
souterrain et c'est extrêmement
difficile
évidemment à combattre c'est des
systèmes à l'ancienne qui
reposent sur sur la confiance mutuelle
qui sont développé dans certain
communauté il y a pas que vers le
Moyen-Orient ça existe aussi plus à
l'est de l'Asie on sait qu'il y a des
réseau chinois qui blanchissent des
sommes considérables comme ça et qui
transfèrent assez facilement de l'argent
d'un point à l'autre du globe juste basé
sur la confiance entre deux personnes et
ça ça restera compliqué à à à
détecter en général tr question pour ma
part la première euh concerne le poste
d'observation euh depuis lequel vous
parlez vous avez commencer votre propos
en disant vous n'étiez pas une une
instance d'évaluation des politiques
publiques mais du coup euh votre regard
comparatif sur ce qui peut être fait ici
et là est intéressant
euh et peut-être que vous avez des
suggestions sans interférer dans un
débat politique national sur quelques
points clés alors vous en avez déjà cité
quelques-uns mais où agréger les
quelques points forts de tel état nous
on se pose la question par exemple des
repentis des infiltrations on a été
interrogé sur des procédure judiciaire
un peu plus discrète parfois donc est-ce
que vous avez peut-être un inventaire un
panorama des des de ce qui fonctionne
deuxième question c'est sur les
messageries cryptées dont vous nous avez
dit et dont on ne cesse de nous répéter
qu'elles sont une vraie vraie difficulté
est-ce qu'il y a quelques pistes pour
arriver à craquer ces M messagerie ou à
s'affranchir de leur rôle majeur dans le
dans le trafic et puis s'agissant de de
de la wala ou des des chambres de
compensation dont vous ves parl est-ce
qu'il y a déjà eu des expériences
concluantes pour en diminuer
l'efficacité ou est-ce que c'est
malheureusement une une tradition qui
échappe aux autorités publiques je crois
que ma collègue Valérie Boyer une
question
complémentaire merci beaucoup monsieur
le présid président général une question
très simple en complément de celle du
président est-ce qu'il y a un endroit où
ce que vous préconisez
fonctionne existe et
fonctionne
euh je vais je vais juste me permettre
monsieur le Président si votre première
question vous avez été un peu haché
quand j'ai quand j'ai reçu vos propos
ont été est-ce que est que j'ai bien
compris vous me parlez des méthodes
d'enquête en fait particulières utilisé
dans dans le domaine du TR de la lutte
contre le trafic de drog oui c'était le
point final avant c'était l'idée c'était
un peu la question de ma collègue Val
Boyer qu'est-ce qui marche et est-ce
qu'on a un inventaire de ce qui marche
et où et est-ce qu'il y a trois quatre
recettes qui agrégé pourrait fonctionner
par exemple la question des repentis
dont on se pose la question de la
légitimité pour le pour le droit
national
français
alors il y a pas de recette miracle je
je crois pas je suis désolé de
devoir dire
ça moi je crois que il y a des endroits
dans lesquels il y a enfin il y a des
pays qu' qu' ont plus de de de
potentialité que ce soit juridique ou
qu'on plus
misé qu'on plus de
de tout simplement des fois de soldats
pour lutter contre un phénomène ou un
autre et cetera euh nous ici ce qu'on
croit beaucoup et ce qu'on voit en fait
c'est que
euh le point un des points clés vraiment
c'est l'échange d'information
euh c'est que
le le
travail au plan national euh j'ai j'ai
envie de dire et je mets mes mains comme
ça à dessin euh que au plan national euh
ça produit des résultats
plus faible euh évidemment si on parle
sur des grands groupes criminels que
l'échange d'information alors je
l'évoque souvent pour Europol parce que
c'est ce qu'on fait tous les jours de la
coopération internationale de l'échange
d'information mettre les gens autour de
la table et cetera souvent c'est plus
compliqué c'est plus compliqué pour les
enquêteurs parce qu'on se frotte avec
des pays qui ne parlent pas notre langue
qui n'ont pas le même cadre juridique
que nous donc on a des difficultés qui
n'ont pas le système le même système
judiciaire que nous parfois donc on a
des difficultés à monter les dossiers à
les coordonné et cetera pour autant
c'est ce qu'on fait tous les jours et
nos plus grands succès ils sont issus de
cette coopération internationale de cet
échange d'information et de cet effort
qui est fait d'aller
euh augmenter l'impact sur les réseaux
criminels à travers la coopération
internationale
et moi je déplore parfois que que ce
soit au niveau des enquêteurs ou parfois
au niveau des autorités judiciaire il y
ait de la réticence à
aller à l'international parce que c'est
plus long c'est plus compliqué on
complique les dossiers il faut savoir
qui va les juger dans quel et et en
fait les criminels utilisent à fond cet
avantage euh c'est-à-dire que euh pour
eux et ben le le il y a pas de
frontières il y a pas de loi ils font la
leure où ils veulent comme ils veulent
et cetera et et c'est dans ce domaine à
mon avis que il y a le plus de de il y a
le plus à faire alors euh pour justement
instaurer un réflexe de partage
d'information même une information qui
paraît anodine euh
pour la France ou euh peut se révéler
crucial pour la Belgique ou l'Espagne ou
ou la Pologne ou les États-Unis ou Dubaï
ou quelque part ailleurs et nous notre
rôle aujourd'hui c'est principalement ça
c'est d'essayer de convaincre toujours
plus de travailler avec nous de de et et
d'aller à l'international euh euh
après il y a pas un pays qui se
distingue
alors nos collègues américains ont des
méthodes
d'investigation très offensives
euh qui marchent mais qui sont porteuses
de qui marchent parfois mais qui sont
porteuses de risque hein ils font des
achats de de produits ils investissent
de l'argent pour acheter de la
drogue limite de ce que dans notre droit
on appelle la provocation parfois
parfois on est même au-delà de la limite
mais leur cadre juridique leur permet de
le faire euh par exemple vous parliez
des chambres de compensation ils sont
capables d'envoyer des agents infiltrés
déposer de l'argent et cetera pour et
puis quitte à le perdre d'ailleurs
parfois des sommes importantes pour
identifier le réseau et cetera ce que
nous en Europe je dirais on n'est pas
prêt à faire parce que on considère
qu'on participe à la commission de
l'infraction et on est dans la
provocation donc ça c'est des méthode
d'enquête agressive entre guillemets
euh c'est pas pas à moi de porter le
débat mais elles existent dans certains
pays où est le point d'équilibre entre
le respect des liberté puis
la la lutte entre la provocation et et
le coût
d'achat c'est pas toujours évident mais
c'est des méthodes qui peuvent marcher
et que certains utilisent en Europe
globalement on a à peu près tous la même
la même ligne directrice qui est de pas
rentrer
là-dedans sur les
sur les messageries cryptées bah je
crois qu'on a prouvé que c'était
possible de la France en premier de les
intercepter on a aussi des dispositions
juridiques en France par rapport à ça
qui
permettent de de de faire des
investigations efficaces quand on a
connaissance d'une messagerie cryptée
qui n'est pas déclaré à
Lancy qui a pu être monté par n'importe
qui et je pense que ce cadre juridique
euh qu'on a créé dans notre pays a été
regardé avec beaucoup d'intérêt suite
aux affaires en crchat et Sky ECC euh
par d'autres pays européens donc là on
va on va progresser après les moyens
technologique de de de de casser le
chiffre sur des messageries cryptées
c'est extrêmement compliqué il faut
savoir où sont les serveurs donc il y a
tout un travail à la fois de ce qu'on
appelle forum Py
numérique et de renseignement et
d'information qui est à faire donc il y
a beaucoup de choses à aligner pour
réussir à à travailler sur ces
messageries mais on en a jusqu'à présent
à Europol on a on a traité quatre
dossiers plus ou moins
importants dans ce domaine là on
désespère pas d'en faire d'autres et
donc ça nous paraît être un un
moyen efficace de de détecter alors
après les criminels suite aux très
grandes messageries comme encroochat ou
Sky ECC il travaillent aussi aujourd'hui
avec des messageries où il y a moins de
personnes
connectées et il préfèrent travailler
peut-être avec deux ou trois petites
messageries qu'avec une grande dans
lesquelles il y a dans laquelle il y a
trop de monde mais je crois qu'on a les
moyens de le faire il faut un cadre
juridique
pertinent c'est comme pour l'échange
d'information si vous me donnez une
minute je je voulais aussi évoquer ça
parce que
euh on est en train à la recherche de
l'équilibre dans un monde qui est de
plus en plus digital on est à la
recherche d'un équilibre en fait pour
tout ce qui concerne les données la data
comment on dit à la recherche d'un
équilibre qu'on a trouvé dans le monde
réel entre sécurité je dirais et liberté
et et et et en gros c'est l'objet d'un
débat c'est l'objet du débat par exemple
autour des durées de rétention c'est
l'objet du débat
autour des de l'accès à des données
personnelles c'est le les données du
débat autour du chiffrement
déchiffrement et et et on sent bien que
dans ce domaine là alors que dans un
monde qui est numérique la donnée la
data elle est au centre des
investigations modernes
on sent bien qu'elle est aussi au centre
de la protection d'un certain nombre de
citoyens et cetera et qu'il nous faut
trouver euh le juste équilibre qu'on est
en train de chercher du côté de de des
forces de l'ordre évidemment ce qu'on
voudrait c'est sous des supervision
euh sous la supervision je dirais de par
exemple de de de la knil en France ou du
contrôleur européen de la protection des
données personnelles qui supervise le
travail d'Europol ici euh sous la
supervision des magistrats évidemment et
avec des autorisations adéquates qu'on
puisse quand c'est nécessaire accéder à
certaines données digitales euh crypté
et euh si possible à chaque fois que
possible en clair et et ça c'est un vrai
sujet c'est un vrai débat c'est pas
uniquement pour le trafic et les
organisations du trafic de stupéfiance
et pour toutes les organisations
criminelles qui parfois abusent euh de
de ces systèmes de
chiffrement Olivier Cadic merci beaucoup
merci pour votre intervention moi ma
première question portera sur la
mutualisation des des forces de police
j'aimerais on a tous connaissance de
laadea aux États-Unis de son son impact
tant pour l'enquête que pour la réaction
est-ce que au niveau d'Europol quelle
est votre vision juste justement sur le
côté organisation combien de est-ce que
Europol est directement implanté en
Amérique latine comment comment est-ce
que ça
fonctionne lors de nos premières
auditions on a observé des des
fonctionnements différents au sein de
l'Union européenne on a vu à Amsterdam
que il y avait dans l'aéroport des
structures pour lorsqu'on arrêtait les
gens d'après ce qu'on nous a expliqué
avec des structures de éventuellement
d'incarcération des contrôles en amont
pour savoir si une personne avait ingéré
de la drogue alors que nous on nait pas
la possibilité de le faire à grande
échelle est-ce que au niveau européen il
y a une forme d'organisation de
réflexion organisée qui se pose dans ce
domaine ensuite pour le blanchiment il y
a quand même un sujet qui est souvent
revenu pour moi dans dans les
discussions que j'ai pu avoir
avec les forces de police c'est la
question des casinos euh vous avez pas
mentionné ce ce sujet or on voit
certains pays
certains certaines localisations qui
utilisent beaucoup ces casinos qui se
positionnent dans les ports les lieux
justement les points de de hub de
transport donc est-ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous suivez ma troisième
question traite aussi une partie dont
vous n'avez pas parlé qui est en Asie
qui est un peu ce qui est ce que
certains appelaient le le triangle d'or
la hausse Thaïlande Birmanie on voit que
par exemple à Sing pour m'a répondu que
personne nétait capable de me dire
combien d'argent arrivait de Birmanie de
Myanmar est-ce que le Myanmar est un
sujet aussi pour vous que vous suivez
Europol
enfin la il y a la question des fonds
des investissements qui proviennent de
de Chine de Hong Kong
euh pour tous tous ceux qui sont dans la
finance on me dit que bah tout ce qui
vient de Hong Kong de Chine c'est devenu
un peu totalement opaque pour le niveau
financier est-ce qu'une action est
envisagée euh euh de la part de de
l'Europe pour justement pouvoir avoir
des des éléments d'information pour les
fonds qui qui arrive de Chine et puis un
dernier point puisque vous avez très
très bien mentionné et décrit un certain
nombre de problématique lié à la
compensation nous il y a quelque chose
qu'on l'on observe en Afrique qui se
développe c'est aussi
l'approvisionnement d'équipements
informatique Télécom qui sont achetés
par de la monnaie locale et qui arrivent
directement dans des containerses euh
qui passe sans déclaration et c'est une
façon aujourd'hui de compensation on n'
pas que de l'argent d'un côté de
l'argent de l'autre c'est parfois aussi
des produit et ça rend justement les
choses très complexes comme vous vous
l'avez dit mais c'est aussi un sujet à
mon avis de proccupation de
triangulation pour le blanchiment merci
oui merci pour vos questions je je vais
essayer d'y répondre dans dans l'ordre
bon en terme d'organisation euh
euh le le principe de l'Union européenne
c'est que chaque État membre
s'organise comme il le
souhaite et que Europol est là en fait
pour faire de la coordination créer des
liens mais que on travaille avec les
organisations nationales telles qu'elles
sont déterminées par les autorités
nationales
euh donc sur les organisations internes
aux États-membres je dirais on nous on
on ne se prononce pas mais on travaille
avec tous ceux qui sont je dirais
validés par leur état membres comme
étant des interlocuteurs d'Europol
vis-à-vis de l'extérieur et c'était une
des questions que vous posiez à propos
de l'Amérique du Sud Europol est
certainement un point d'entrée
c'est-à-dire que Europol est connu par
exemple vous vous évoquez l'Amérique du
Sud on a développé pas mal
d'investigations ces dernières années
avec l'Amérique du Sud on a une très
bonne coopération avec le Brésil on en a
une depuis longtemps avec la
Colombie l'Équateur la Bolivie et le
Pérou sont demandeuses de plus de
coopération avec Europol et voit Europol
comme un possible point d'entrée parce
que en fait si je prends par exemple
l'exemple de la de la Colombie on voit
qu' en Colombie il y
a il y a des équipes d'enquête
d'enquêteurs qui sont il y a une équipe
il y a des équipes françaises il y a des
équipes espagnoles il y a des équipes
néerlandaises des équipes nationales et
donc qui travaill en direct et puis il y
a Europol qui apparaît à ces pays comme
un un beau po d'entrée pour rentrer sur
le niveau européen pour qu'on les aide
en terme de renseignement en terme
d'analyse criminelle mais aussi en terme
de financement de certaines réunions et
cetera donc je pense que ce rôle
deuropol il est il est de mieux en mieux
reconnu au fur à mesure des
investigations qu'on soutient il est
reconnu non seulement par nos
États-membres mais il est reconnu par
les des
étatstiers avec lesquels nous
travaillons et et
donc en terme d'organisation
moi je pense que euh l'agence à laquelle
j'appartiens aujourd'hui a vraiment une
plusvalue à apporter bah dans les
limites des ressources qui lui sont
attribuées évidemment mais a une
plusvalue à apporter et regardé comme un
interlocuteur valable y compris par
exemple vous ctiez la DEA he j'ai
moi-même été aux États-Unis rencontré
laadea l'administratrice de laadea est
venue à Europol donc je pense qu'on est
reconnu et compris par le partenaire
américain comme un une une organisation
et un point d'entrée solide pour rentrer
sur n'importe quelle problématique en
Europe et on peut faire le relais avec
nos États-membres
euh sans s'inscrire d'ailleurs jamais en
concurrence des États-membres mais
toujours en complément en terme de
valeur ajoutée et ça je pense que c'est
extrêmement important que Europol
continue d'ajouter de la valeur à ce que
font les États-membres et ne se pose pas
en en en concurrent euh et et c'est ce
qu'on s'efforce de faire votre question
sur les casinos
euh on on ne suit pas spécifiquement
euh ce
domainel on est plus préoccupé par ce
qu'on appelle nous à vrai dire des
juridictions no coopérative
euh on sait qu'il y a de l'argent qui va
dans
certains dans certains endroits euh où
il peut être très facilement sans aller
sans passer par le casino euh blanchi et
réinvesti en terme d'immobilier en terme
de services divers et variés ou dépenser
sur place et cetera et et c'est c'est
plus ça nos préoccupations euh je dirais
que le le le contrôle des casinos même
si le blanchiment que vous évoquez il
existe et dans un peu le partage des
tâches c'est plutôt aux États-membres
pour nous de contrôler ça et nous on n'
pas tellement euh une vision là-dessus
sur votre question sur euh l'Asie la
Birmanie et cetera on a assez peu
jusqu'à présent de relation
euh en Asie dans ce domainelà il faut
bien voir que le le la ligne directrice
de l'action d'uropol c'est le soutien
des investigations de nos États-membres
ça veut dire que pour qu'on aille en
Asie et par exemple en Birmanie il faut
qu'on ait deux États-membres qui a une
enquête sur je pas du blanch d'argent
qui proviendrait de cette zone là et
cetera et à ce moment-là on va on va s'y
intéresser de plus près mais on
fonctionne un peu au dossier
nous vraiment avec une une focale
opérationnelle donc et puis on n' pas la
ressource non plus de couvrir le monde
entier malheureusement donc on se
concentre sur là où sont les intérêts
des
enquêteurs de nos enquêteurs et des
enquêteurs des étatsmembres donc sur la
Birmanie j'ai pas beaucoup de de
d'informations sur la Chine et Hong Kong
euh ben là aussi il y a des actions qui
sont entreprises au niveau européen
euh je pense que là aussi l'initiative
sur le le blanchiment d'argent enfin le
l'autorité antiblanchiment qui va être
montée d'ailleurs don je crois que notre
pays
a et candidat pour en accueillir le
siège euh cette autorité
antiblanchiment euh je crois que c'est
c'est dans dans ce genre d'autorité et
et par la relation de ces de ces
secteurs là que que doivent se faire la
surveillance sur ces pays-là nous encore
une fois on sait qu'il y a des réseaux
de blanchiment chinois et on essaie de
travailler dessus d'ailleurs en
coopération avec d'autres pays euh mais
mais je dirais on n' pas d'information
particulière sur les flux financiers qui
arrivent de Chine et de Hong Kong qui
peuvent être réinvestis sauf enquête
particulière et puis votre dernière
question que évoquer les compensations
vous avez totalement raison euh les
compensations se font pas seulement en
argent on a vu des échanges de produits
hein c'est-à-dire cocaïne contre
cannabis euh cocaïne contre drogue
synthétique cocaïne contre armes ou
armes contre cocaïne euh donc euh vous
avez totalement raison je l'avais pas
évoqué mais c'est évidemment quelque
chose qu'on surveille de près en
particulier quand ces échanges se font
avec par exemple des armes dans
certaines zones c'est évidemment crucial
mais aussi avec d'autres produits et
vous avez raison la compensation elle
est pas uniquement en argent elle peut
être en service et elle peut être
également en fourniture
d'autres
d'autres dirais produits qui peuvent
être
trafiqués
oui merci mon
général on a parlé tout des coopérations
européennes le sentiment que l'on a plus
on avance dans nos
investigations c'est que aujourd'hui
tous les pays d'Europe sont dépassés par
ce phénomèneut dépasser le terme est un
peu excessif mais quand on utilise le
terme de narcoétat pour parler de la
Belgique pour parler de la Hollande
quand on prend la mesure de ce qui se
passe sur nos
ports et la mesure de la corruption qui
touche pas seulement les dockers mais
aussi des services de l'État
régulièrement la presse son fait l'écho
donc on a le sentiment sur le plan
européen en tout cas pour la France que
le narcotrafic court un peu plus vite
que les politiques publiques et que les
moyens affectés n'arrivent pas Ener le
phénomène qui
s'amplifie la réponse vous l' très bien
dit tout à l'heure elle est en grande
partie européenne elle est dans des
coopérations notamment pour mieux
surveiller les flux surveiller les port
surveiller le blanchiment est-ce que
vous pourriez nous dire sur quelle
thématique particulière aujourd'hui
Europol est associé à des réflexion sur
l'évolution
potentielle des politiques européennes
dans ce domaine et on a abordé de
manière un peu superficielle la question
du blanchiment la question de l'échange
d'information est-ce que de manière
précise vous pourriez nous dire voilà
sur telle évolution de politique nous
Europol on a été sollicité on a apporté
notre concours
et on a des suggestions précises à
formuler
oui alors bon je peux vous prendre
quelques exemples effectivement on est
parce que un des rôles de l'agence c'est
aussi elle est régulièrement consultée
pour ça de de à travers en particulier
ses rapports dont la plupart sont
public en tout cas ont une version
publique c'est aussi de de nourrir la
réflexion euh au niveau des des
décideurs politiques et par exemple si
vous prenez l'initiative qui va être don
j' que j'évoqué rapidement à laquelle
d'ailleurs je crois enverse notre
ministre de l'Intérieur va
participer mercredi euh sous présidence
belge qui est le lancement d'une
alliance des ports européens pour
consolider
euh je dirais le la sécurité et évoquer
euh
le évoquer le durcissement entre
guillemets de ses ports bon ben ce ce
travail là il est directement issu du
rapport que j'ai là entre les
mains qui
s'appelle criminal networks in euorts
risk and challenges for law enforcement
c'est un rapport qui a été publié par
eurol je sa plus exactement la date mais
c'était il y a en mars 202 3 donc vous
voyez que c'était pas il y a pas très
longtemps ce rapport qu'on a élaboré
avec les ports de envers Rotterdam et
euh Hambourg en fait
euh décrit un certain nombre de moyens
de sortir de la drogue des ports des
containers et cetera et c'est clairement
ce rapport qui est à l'origine de
l'initiative qui va être prise par la
présidence belge au niveau européens
pour consolider en fait la sécurité dans
les ports vis-à-vis du trafic euh de
stupéfiant mais pas seulement
euh donc on a là été non seulement
associé mais on a été à
l'origine je dirais de de cette
initiative à travers ce rapport j'ai eu
moi-même il y a pas longtemps une une
réunion avec le World shipping Council
qui est le l'organisation qui regroupe
tous les grands transporteurs maritimes
mondio CMA CGM pour la France mais MSC
et d'autres y compris les transporteurs
chinois d'ailleurs qui qui siège
à je me souviens plus si à New York ou à
Washington mais aux États-Unis j'ai une
vidéoconférence avec eux pour les
sensibiliser et essayer de voir comment
on pouvait travailler ensemble donc on
travaille sur ces sujetsl on a été
associé à la réglementation européenne
sur le antioney laundering donc sur le
le blanchiment d'argent ou notre centre
de lutte contre la criminalité
économique et financière a été
auditionné plusieurs fois au Parlement
européen a été aussi auditionné au
Conseil a pu parler avec la commission
pour essayer de mettre en place des
choses qui qui se révèlent pertinentes
on a eu aussi il y a 18 mois une
modification du règlement
d'uropol pour résoudre les
problématiques posées par les ce qu'on
appelle le Big Data challenge
c'est-à-dire les les les les sets de
données que consid
qu'on reçoit et on a un nouveau cadre
juridique qui nous permet de faire plus
de choses depuis donc juin 2022 qui nous
permet de faire plus de choses et à
l'origine il y a une réflexion de la
commission mais il y a
aussi aussi des décisions du du du CEPD
du contrôleur européen de la protection
des données mais aussi une une action
proactive de l'agence pour dire on a
besoin d'un autre cadre juridique pour
pouvoir travailler sur de la donnée et
on est associé par exemple j'ai vu dans
le questionnaire que vous évoqueiez une
initiative de la présidence suédoise qui
s'appelle going dark euh qui euh en fait
est autour euh de du chiffrement et euh
et de l'utilisation par les enfin de la
possibilité pour les forces de l'ordre
d'accéder à des informations euh qui
seraiit chiffré et et et comment dire
échanger bon typiquement euh le le
groupe de niveau qui se réunit sous
l'autorité du Conseil européen dans ce
domaine là going dark Europol en fait
partie et Europol a a pu soutenir cette
initiative donc oui nous sommes associés
oui nous sommes proactifs aussi souvent
que possible pour essayer de mettre sur
la table les sujets on est parfois aussi
contrebalancé par des lobby important
parce que évidemment quand on parle des
ports ou des on est évidemment dans dans
le commerce
mondial je m'étais amusé à sortir les
chiffres des principaux ports européens
je crois que notre port du Havre il doit
faire 4 millions de containire par an si
je me souviens bien quand Rotterdam en
fait 14
euh donc évidemment les possibilité de
contrôle il y a j'ai visité le port de
Rotterdam c'est c'est 2000 comp à
l'heure qui arrive donc le le contrôle
je dirais à la frontière du container
c'est pas facile donc c'est là où
l'échange d'information est évidemment
crucial les techniques de ciblage que
nos camarades douaniers mettent en place
et cetera sont sont absolument
nécessaires un autre sujet que je peux
évoquer c'est l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle dont on voit
qu'elle qu'elle pose des difficultés en
terme de protection des données personn
en terme de biais des algorithmes et
cetera mais qui est une aide
considérable quand on quand on travaille
sur des masses
d'information absolument gigantesque et
dont on a besoin nous pour faire notre
travail d'analyse criminelle et pour
savoir où est-ce qu'on doit appliquer
notre
action alors je Bala du regard la salle
pour voir si on encore des questions
auprès de chez nos collègues mais ça ne
s pas être le cas il nous reste vous
remercier très chaleureusement pour la
qualité de ses échanges la franchise de
votre propos et sa grande clarté et puis
on va continuer notre mission en
espérantir l'occasion de trouver des
solutions pour qu'on améliore le travail
commun merci beaucoup en général merci
monsieur le Président on y travaille
tous les jours soyez-en sûr rassure
merci beaucoup bonne journée
y